THOMPSON: I would like to welcome you to today's
Council on Foreign Relations Malcolm and Carolyn
Wiener Annual Lecture on Science and Technology.
The title today is "Artificial Intelligence
and the Rise of the Robots" with Rodney Brooks,
Abhinav Gupta and Andrew McAfee.
Rodney Brooks is a Panasonic professor of
robotics, Computer Science and Artificial
Intelligence Lab at MIT. But he is known in
my family, I have three little boys, and he
is known as the inventor of the Roomba. And
in fact, this morning, I was having a hard
time getting my kids dressed. Roomba is a
little electronic vacuum cleaner that my toddler
surfs on and the older kids love. I told my
kids I have to get to work on time since I
was interviewing the man who invented the
Roomba and they got dressed like that. Rodney
Brooks, a very important man.
Abhinav Gupta is an assistant research professor
at the Robotics Institute at Carnegie Mellon
University. He is doing some of the most interesting
and cutting-edge research we have on the way
artificial intelligence can work with visual
extraction technologies.
Andrew McAfee is the principle research scientist
and cofounder of the initiative on digital
economy at the Sloan School at MIT. You have
probably all seen his book, The Second Machine
Age. If you haven't seen it, you've seen reviews
of it. I work at the New Yorker and we actually
used a draft of a review of his book as an
edit test. So I have read 100 copies of a
review of your book. That was so bad, we made
it into an edit test. Sorry about that.
OK. A special thanks to Malcolm and Carolyn
Wiener for making this lectureship possible.
They are here in the audience. We just had
a lovely lunch talking with them. We were
very grateful. This is an extremely important
topic.
And I would also like to welcome the CFR members
around the nation and the world participating
in this meeting through the live stream.
We are going to begin with a video to help
us understand what exactly is going on. So
if someone could please queue up Baxter. This
is one of the many robots that Rodney Brooks
has brought into the world. So, Baxter.
(BEGIN VIDEOTAPE)
(UNKNOWN): Think adding automation to your
production line limits you to high costs,
high volume, caged robots? Think automation
requires specialized robots programmed by
highly-trained engineers? Well, think again.
Baxter breaks out from the productive cages
that contain many manufacturing robots, allowing
people and robots to work side by side, doing
what each does best. From machine tending
to line loading, to packing and unpacking,
Baxter has the flexibility to be deployed
and redeployed on tasks with minimal setup
or integration costs. Whether there is increased
customer demand or the introduction of a new
product, Baxter helps you create a collaborative
workforce, one with increased productivity
and efficiency.
Think about getting all this for a base price
of $25,000. That translates into an ROI of
months, not years.
Now think about what Baxter could add to your
plant. Rethink manufacturing. Rethink what's
next. Rethink robotics.
(END VIDEOTAPE)
BROOKS: In my defense, I did not choose that
video.
THOMPSON: That is an excellent video. I hope
everybody's excited.
BROOKS: Well, it's a little selling and I
wouldn't have chosen the selling one.
THOMPSON: It's like a Super Bowl ad. After
watching that, I replaced the entire staff
of the New Yorker website with Baxters and
it's been going quite well for the last two
weeks. I hope you all visit newyorker.com.
Abhinav, would you like to—we're going to
begin with the hardest stuff first. So Abhinav,
I want you to give some background on what
NEIL is so we can understand it, and then
we will jump right into the big topics everybody
wants to hear about, how the economy is changing,
how the world is changing, how the military
is changing and how long everyone in this
room will still have their jobs until they're
replaced with robots.
BROOKS: Forever, forever.
THOMPSON: Not everybody if I've read all your
work.
Abhinav, do you want to start with NEIL?
GUPTA: Before I start, I think I should say
that I also have a Baxter in my lab and I'm
a big fan of Baxter. It's changing at least
research completely with the price point which
it has.
THOMPSON: Andy, do you have a Baxter?
MCAFEE: I do not yet.
THOMPSON: Do you have a Roomba?
GUPTA: You should buy one.
MCAFEE: Well, Rod and I are neighbors. I'm
just going to go over and see his in Cambridge.
THOMPSON: All right. Abhinav?
GUPTA: OK. So before I give an introduction
to NEIL, let me just first talk about why
we need NEIL. And so if you think, there are
things we humans—like facts we humans just
seem to know about. For example, all of us
here know sheeps are white, cars have wheels,
babies have eyes, and so on. So these kind
of facts, which I like to call common sense
knowledge, it's not clear how we learned them.
But what is clear to me is that we use common
sense every day and every moment of our lives.
For example, if you see a boxy object outside
on the road with a wheel, you will all know
that this is a car. So you are using your
common sense to reason about objects. You
use common sense to reason about physics.
You fill your dishwasher so that by putting
on one more dish, one more dish, and you know
your common sense tells you that it's starting
to fall. You use common sense to predict what's
going to happen next. So if you throw a ball
up, you know it's going to come down.
Now this common sense, which is so obvious
to you and me, it's completely tricky and
totally inaccessible to computers right now.
Why? Just think of the skill. How many such
facts can I write? Billions, trillions. I
mean, I don't even—I cannot even count how
many such facts will exist for us to know
what is truth in this world, what—how does
our world work.
So at CMU, at Carnegie Mellon, we have been
taking an approach where we are building NEIL.
NEIL is Never Ending Image Learner. It's a
computer program that runstwenty-four hours
a day, seven days a week. It's running right
now as we are going to have this conversation.
And what it is trying to do is something very
simple. All it does is it downloads hundreds
of boring images of our world every day. It
tries to understand those images using the
advances in AI. And as it understands more
and more images, it's basically experiencing
the world. And as it is experiencing, it is
learning more and more common sense facts
about the world. And by learning more common
sense facts, it kind of becomes much more
smarter and smarter in understanding the world
around us.
So for example, NEIL knows our concepts and
relationships. Like it knows that Columbia
can have four different meanings and it learns
all this automatically without having a single
human in the loop. So it knows Columbia could
be Columbia University, which is like nearby.
It could be Columbia Sportswear Company, which
is making jackets, shoes and so on. Columbia
could be Columbia River, or it could be Columbia
Pictures.
And then, NEIL has also been learning relationships.
MCAFEE: It's not aware there's a country?
GUPTA: It has not learned it's a country.
So yeah, there is some—there are some gaps,
I have to say.
BROOKS: It's only three years old.
MCAFEE: Sorry.
GUPTA: It's actually one year old.
BROOKS: Oh, one year old.
GUPTA: So NEIL is just one year old. Country
is probably harder than you would say.
So just to point out that the kind of common
sense relationships NEIL has learned, for
example, trading floors are crowded. It has
learned things like Corolla is a kind of a
car, cars have wheels. It has learned things
like bamboo forests havevertical lines,
and so on.
So it has been running for one year, as Rodney
pointed out. So it's still a baby. I should
ask any other baby how much he or she knows
to compare. It has learned more than four
million objects in the world, at this point
of time, 20,000 relationships. And as it grows
older and older, my hope—it might not happen,
as Andrew points out that there are some holes—my
hope is that it will be able to understand
better and better about our world, using images
and videos.
THOMPSON: It is a terrifying thought of someone
just surfing the web and learning everything
about the web. They must know a lot about
llamas today, too. I hope NEIL does.
MCAFEE: They still don't know what color that
damn dress is. No insight on that.
THOMPSON: Nobody does. This is the biggest
mystery of the --
(CROSSTALK)
GUPTA: Computers agree on the color of the
dress.
THOMPSON: Baxter knows.
OK. Rodney, let's talk about where robots
are. You've been a leader in this field for
at leastthirty-five years. You wrote your
first seminal controversial paper trying to
answer the question that I'm about to askthirty-fiveyears
ago, I believe. But—what are they good at;
what are they not good at?
BROOKS: Robots are good at very simple tasks.
They're not good at complex tasks. They're
certainly not good—here's something that
if a venture capitalist offered me money to
build a company around, I would not take it,
even though I love taking money from venture
capitalists but I'm too honest. I would not
say, you know, give me $25 million and I'll
work on a robot that can do this.
[Removes keys from pocket.]
Way, way too hard. Way to dexterous. Way too
hard. We have no idea how to do that level
of dexterity. In fact, in what you saw in
the video was Baxter with either just two
fingers going like this, without any touch
sensing, or a suction cup sucking. Dexterity,
we're terrible at. We haven't done at all
well in the lastfifty years.
THOMPSON: Why?
BROOKS: Because hands are very complex and
you need to work on four simultaneous pieces
of science at once. You need to work on different
kinematics. You need to work on materials
because our hands are very dependent on materials.
You need to work on sensing and you need to
work on algorithms all at once and we just
have not succeeded.
THOMPSON: But aren't prosthetic hands a great
medical success of the last few years? Or
is that a --
BROOKS: But there's a person in the control
loop.
THOMPSON: Right. So it's the control loop
for the dexterity. It's not the physical dexterity.
BROOKS: You need both in order to succeed.
So robots are good at very simple things like
cleaning the floor, like doing a repetitive
task. Our robots have a little tiny bit of
common sense. Our robots know that if they've
got something in their hand and they drop
it, it's gone. They shouldn't go and try and
put it down. So they—that's a bit of common
sense that, traditionally, industrial robots
have not had. But we just put each of our
piece of common sense in one by one, rather
than automatically.
So I think people get confused by seeing Hollywood
movies and see what the robots can do there,
but we are a long, long way from having robots
that can do that.
THOMPSON: Are battery technologies a main
limitation right now as well?
BROOKS: You know, battery—battery technologies
are certainly a—for mobile robots, they're
certainly an issue. But we don't have the
technology to get the energy density conversion
that human muscle has, even if we had the
batteries.
THOMPSON: OK.
Well, Andy, one of your greatthemes is how
these different kind of robots are advancing
and what jobs they will eliminate. So let
me just read off some of the professional
affiliations of the people in this room; JPMorgan
Chase, Centerra Capital, Markle Foundation,
Passur Aerospace, New York Presbyterian Hospital,
The Dana Foundation. Who is most likely to
lose their job first to a robot?
MCAFEE: Probably someone like me, who tries
to survey a big mass of unstructured information,
draw a hopefully correct conclusion or an
inference based on that large amount of information,
and then try to communicate that insight to
a broad audience. Digital technologies are
now pretty good at all of those tasks, and
getting better along a Moore’s Law kind
of trajectory, an exponential trajectory,
as opposed to a linear trajectory.
And the reason that we wrote the book and
what's fundamentally interesting to me is,
really smart guys, previous generations of—and
above Rod, have been working on a set of problems
for as long as we've had computers. Call it
half a century. The progress they made was
deeply underwhelming from any practical point
of view.
And then just in the past few years, digital
technologies and all their manifestations,
including robots, have been breaking out of
the little box where they'd been operating
and starting to demonstrate capabilities that
they never, ever had before that are really
impressive when you look at it. They're economically
significant and we're seeing human-level and,
in many cases, superhuman performance in some
fundamentally important areas, like unstructured
search, like natural language processing,
like image recognition and image processing
and image classification. A lot of these things
that technologies were, traditionally lousy
at, they're now really, really good and getting
a lot better all the time. This was pretty
unprecedented and unexpected and I think it's
going to—it's already having pretty serious
economic consequences. I think they're going
to get bigger.
BROOKS: Can I respond to that a little bit?
MCAFEE: No.
THOMPSON: They've started fighting already.
BROOKS: People always want us to fight, but
we don't really.
I think, although I agree with the general
themes that Andy talks about, I think it's
very easy for people who are not deep in the
technology itself to make generalizations,
which may be a little dangerous. And we've
certainly seen that recently with Elon Musk,
Bill Gates, Stephen Hawking, all saying AI
is just taking off and it's going to take
over the world very quickly. And the thing
that they share is none of them work in this
technological field.
So let me explain why—and they're all smart
people, but I think they're making a fundamental
error and it gets to NEIL, actually.
THOMPSON: After taking down Bill Gates, Elon
Musk and Stephen Hawking, he's going to take
down the Dalai Lama.
Please continue, Rodney.
BROOKS: So let's go back to an example from
the '90s, when IBM's Deep Blue beat Kasparov,
beat the world chess champion. And Kasparov
got up and said, well, at least it didn't
enjoy beating me. That was his—holding on
to his humanity.
And now, today, you can get programs that
run on—and that was on a supercomputer and
now you can get programs that run on laptops.
There's abouttwelve of them that have a
better chess rating than any human being has
ever had. So people see that --
MCAFEE: It's so bad now—let me underscore
what Rod is saying. It's so bad now that they
asked human grand master a couple years ago
how he would prepare for a match against a
computer and he said, I'd bring a hammer.
BROOKS: So they can play chess really, really
well. And I think people generalize that in
the way that if a person can do some task
really, really well, they can do adjacent
tasks quite well. But none of those chess
programs can play tic-tac-toe. Imagine a chess
grand master who couldn't play tic-tac-toe.
It doesn't make sense. None of those chess
programs can give advice to an aspiring human
on how to play better. All they can be is
a sparring partner.
MCAFEE: That program couldn't play tic-tac-toe
without being substantially redirected, right?
BROOKS: Right. So people, I think, are seeing
some of the image labeling that's going on,
for instance. Google came out with image labeling,
which is a great commercial problem for them.
They want to be able to label images. And
one of the examples was, that Jeff Hinton
shows, one of the chief scientists, is, it's
a picture and it says there's a baby holding
a teddy bear or doll in there. You look at
it, it's a baby holding a teddy—a doll.
But then if you ask the program, where is
the baby? All it can say is, well, this pixel
has 10 percent probability of being a baby,
this pixel has 80 percent. And people have
done experiments. You have a mashup of, you
know, a grotesque mashup of baby parts and
it says it's a baby. It's a baby. It's got
all the parts. But a person says, no, that's
a grotesque mashup of baby parts in the image.
THOMPSON: But Abhinav, you've solved this,
right?
GUPTA: No, no, no.
BROOKS: Well, he's working towards --
GUPTA: So, can I --
BROOKS: He's working towards it because it's
such a hard problem.
GUPTA: Yeah, OK. Thank you.
So since we are talking about images, I think
I should chime in a little bit and tell you
that—so what Andrew is talking about, that
we have made big advances, again, they're
very, very specific tasks. Given an image,
tell me what label can you put on that image?
We have gotten really good at this task. Some
people claim even better than humans. I don't
buy that, but let's assume that even better
than humans. But that doesn't mean we can
do anything else apart from that exact task.
And that's what Rodney was talking about.
They have no idea that—what does baby mean?
What does having a baby mean in those images?
No idea. You, as a human, would know, OK,
if I'm saying there's a baby, it has a lot
of meaning inside. You get a lot ofmeaning
out of that thing.
So while we have made significant advances
in the last two years, I want to boil it down
a little bit and say we still are a long,
long way to go but Elon Musk or Bill Gates,
everyone is talking about, we still have a
long way to go. But there's hope, and that's
what I think we have to see here. Two years
ago, if you asked me can computers take an
image and solve this problem, I would say
I have invested seven years of my life but
if you give me a random image, it will not
work. And now, given a randomimage, it will
work. So all it --
MCAFEE: This was the guy who was doing this
for a living and if you asked him two years
ago would this happen, he would say, no. This
progress is weirdly fast and is surprising
insiders in the field.
GUPTA: Yeah. I agree. And I'm an insider in
the field and I'm very surprised, I have to
say. Now, at this point of time, I am like
living in an aweof myself, in some sense,
that—but it was like Rodney told—Rodney
told us that inthirty-five years he never
thought he'd do this all. I also thought some
of it, like that, forthirty-five years,
I will not solve—see this kind of classification
performance. But as I'm saying this, still
a long, long way to go and much harder way
to go. What—where all the kind of gains
have come from is the data. And I think—so
technology, this like deep-learning technology
has been there from '70s and '80s. Don't misunderstand
that this technology came two years ago and
everything's changed. This has been there
forthirty years. It's just that for the
first time in our technological advances we
have data for this deep-learning technology
to learn.
MCAFEE: Let me jump on this because I think
the three of us are really agreeing, instead
of disagreeing. I chose my adjective pretty
carefully. I said these advances are going
to be economically significant. I completely
agree with Rod that they're not going to be
existentially significant on any timeframe
that we really need to worry about, for exactly
the reasons that you're bringing up.
One way to think about this, the way I try
to get my mind around it, is there are, from
what I've been able to take in, there are
something like betweenten andtwenty really
fundamental challenges that these guys and
their discipline have been working on. Common
sense is a really great example of that.
As I've looked around, these breakthroughs
that we're seeing seem to be—kind of indicate
that we're making real progress on one of
those challenges, the challenges of learning
in a pretty unstructured environment. That's
a big deal. There are lots of other fundamental
challenges in the discipline where the progress
has not been as fast, and these are the ones
that you're working on.
GUPTA: So let me add another thing. I mean,
it's economically significant but I see the
positive, unlike him seeing the negative.
I see more jobs created from digital analytics
than jobs being lost here because of digital
analytics.
MCAFEE: I wish the evidence were lining up
with your optimism.
GUPTA: I feel at least, I mean, so what will
happen --
MCAFEE: What you feel is not really a great
counter argument to the balance of the evidence.
GUPTA: I agree. I agree. I'm not an expert
in economics; that's what you are. But what
I feel that over time what we have seen is
the characterization of the jobs will change.
I agree that the characterization—so earlier,
we were like if—suppose Rodney's Baxter
goes into every manufacturing company. Maybewe
will not have people doing manufacturing in
those companies, but we'll have some other
jobs which would come up. And there are two
great examples which I would like to point
out. For example, this digital analytics is
creating so many jobs in health care right
now. My wife was basically employed because
of this—sorry, I --
MCAFEE: How many advanced degrees does your
wife have?
GUPTA: Well, I am—that's what I'm saying.
The characterization of jobs have changed.
And my wife does have advanced degree. I'm
not saying she doesn't have. But what wrong
inhumans having advanced degree? I don't
see—I mean, characterization of jobs will
change, our education might need to change,
but that doesn't mean that are not going to
survive. I mean, we are going to have enough
jobs. Robots are going to be helping us, not
destroying us.
MCAFEE: I agree with exactly half of that.
THOMPSON: Hold on. We've got to pause for
a second here because we are dismantling Andy's
theory without having presented Andy's theory.
A classic example of panel indirection.
So Andy, will you please present your theory
about the economic loss, and then we'll go
back to dismantling it.
MCAFEE: And I want to be clear; I'm an optimist
about technological progress. I get sometimes
painted asa doctor doom, which I think is
a little unfair. Tech progress is the only
free lunch that economists believe in. It's
making the overall pie bigger, unambiguously.
THOMPSON: CFR, I just had a delicious pie
--
MCAFEE: The question is about how we're dividing
up that pie. And the classic bargain for the
era of industrial capitalism for most of us
is you offer your labor, an employer wants
that and you get a decent and better-over-time
middle class living as a result. There is
plenty of evidence that that bargain is under
some stress these days. Median American family,
even after you adjust for household size and
inflation and everything else we can adjust
for, is not making any more money than they
were in the 1990s. The recovery is gaining
some jobs. Most of those jobs are not what
we would call great jobs. They're not highly
paid. They don't have benefits. They're kind
of lower to mid-low range, fairly precarious
jobs. And we're still not generating enough
of them. The labor force participation rates
for the American workforce, even of prime-age
workers, are where they were aboutthirty
years ago, before women entered the workforce
in big numbers.
So as I look around, I see plenty of evidence
that something is changing with that deep
bargain and technology and tech progress is
one of my culprits for it.
THOMPSON: Let me read a tiny bit from an essay
that John Lanchester just wrote in the London
Review of Books that I just read last night.
I came out in this week's issue. "In 1960,
the most profitable company in the world's
biggest economy was General Motors. In today's
money, General Motors made $7.6 billion that
year. It also employed 600,000 people. Today's
most profitable company, Apple, employs 92,600.
So where 600,000 workers would once generate
$7.6 billion in profit, now 92,000 workers
generates $90 billion. An improvement in profitability
per worker of 76.65 times, but the jobs are
disappearing." Which is echoing your argument.
Let's talk about—not about the United States,
but let's talk about the global economic impact
of this transformation that's going on.
Rodney, why don't we start with you? You were,
at lunch, telling us a great story about Roombas
in Spain, which shows the complexity of what's
going on here.
BROOKS: So the Roomba home cleaning robot
from a previous company of mine, iRobot—biggest—fastest
growing market in Europe is in Spain. Spain
has terrible unemployment. Why would people
be buying Roombas to clean their houses? It's
because of the collapse of the construction
industry. The South American workers went
back to South America and their wives went
with them and their wives had been the maidsthat
peoplehad employed. And people, even with
very high unemployment rates, don't want to
be maids in Spain, and so people are buying
Roombas to clean their houses.
So the—it's a complex intertwining of forces.
I don't think it's a very straightforward
one, which the press often takes your statements
and generalizes them to be very straightforward;
more technology, less jobs. It's a complex
--
MCAFEE: And historically, that has not been
true. For 200 years we have had a ton of tech
progress and the average worker has done nothing
but get—but get better off and more employable
over time.
THOMPSON: So why is that different? Why now?
Why is that --
(UNKNOWN): Why this time?
MCAFEE: Because as I said earlier, the technologies
are breaking out of their historical boxes.
They're doing things they could never, ever
do before. And they're eating into the bundle
of skills and abilities that we all have to
offer. They're eating into it in a way that
would we've not seen.
GUPTA: Can I add something? I mean, I just
want to say that he was saying 'I don't have
data", but his data is showing what I was
saying, that with technology the jobs are
increasing; it's not going down. You said
that I didn't have the data.
MCAFEE: Were you tuning out a little earlier
when I talked about some of the statistics?
GUPTA: No, but I'm just saying that—I mean,
that the kind of jobs might change. And I
agree, I mean, that it's kind of—you know
that these jobs of labor and stuff will definitely—(inaudible)—like
in the Spanish things and so on, I mean—but
there is going to be new jobs.
I think the best example I want to put is
my computer learning. At times, liketen
years old, my father would never touch a computer.
He hated computer learning and so on. But
now computer is everywhere in the life. What
happened? The technology of computers came
in and now everyone starts to learn about
computers and now the jobs are like that.
I think the jobs are just going to be much
more different than they are today, and that's
good. I mean, I don't see anything wrong in
that at all.
BROOKS: I want to say that I've become over—I've
been subjected to Andy's books for the last
few years. I've—I used to say, well, why
now, I don't believe now, but I think it's
a little more complex. I would say, by the
way, that Apple, with their 92,000 employees,
also has about 1.5 million people under subcontract
in China, which their boss, Terry Gou, is
desperately trying to replace with robots.
THOMPSON: So my statistic is wrong but it
may be right.
BROOKS: Yes. Well, because it's—are much
more complex. GM just built everything.
But you know, one of the—one of the things
that I've certainly cited before and other
people have cited is that, you know, in the
agricultural revolution, we went from a majority
of the population being in agriculture to
a very small percentage being in agriculture
but it didn't get rid of jobs. But what—and
I was reminded of this as I was walking along
59th Street past the parkto get here,what
did happen was the population of horses plummeted.
There were horses on farms doing work that
were no longer needed. The only gainfully
employed horses left are here in Central Park,
and it's a sad, sad thing. And the question
is whether we're going to be the horses this
time.
MCAFEE: From an economic point of view, that's
the right question. From a societal point
of view, these are our choices to make. We
get to decide whether we become irrelevant
or not, and I certainly hope that we don't.
But people who are blithe about job and wage
prospects have one pretty important phenomena
to explain away. It's the fact that in the
majority of countries around the world, high-wage
ones, certainly, but even low-wage countries
as diverse as Mexico, India and China, the
share of GDP every year, getting paid out
in wages, is going down. It's going down fairly
quickly. We've not seen this before. And we're
not outsourcing to Mars. So the globalization
is not part of the phenomenon there. But the
classic structure in the bargain is shifting.
BROOKS: There's a much more complex thing.
You talked earlier—and we haven't talked
about this—you talked earlier about the
contract between working for a company, getting
a middle class job. Along with that, the company
took on the risk of stabilizing your employment,
stabilizing your income and other benefits.
And what we're seeing now is a different sort
of company coming along which doesn't have
employees but has contractors. And it ranges
from Airbnb to Uber, different sorts of models
of interaction, but across—even UPS trucks,
FedEx trucks, the whole way that workers and
companies relate, and it's being greased by
information technology. But not about AI.
It's just about being able to track things.
So --
MCAFEE: About really powerful platforms, sure.
THOMPSON: So let's say I'm Barack Obama and
I have to come up with a national industrial
policy, and I recognize these trends that
you're talking about. I see the economy transforming.
I recognize that robots are coming. Baxter
will only have more Baxters and better Baxters
in the future, even if they can't take the
keys out of their pockets. What should I do,
if I'm Barack Obama and I want to adjust our
economy? Well, I'm not. I'm just a guy, but
you know, what should America's policy be?
MCAFEE: Are you cold-calling or do you just
want to us to shoot off our mouths if we feel
the urge?
THOMPSON: I'm asking you to shoot off your
mouths.
MCAFEE: So in the short term, I find this
a pretty easy question to answer. In the short
term, despite the hard work of guys like this,
the robots and the AI are not about to take
all of our jobs. They can't do most of our
jobs yet. So the right recipe for now is grow
the economy more quickly. The jobs will come
along with it. I completely agree with Larry
Summers on this point.
So then the question is what's the econ 101
playbook for right now?
THOMPSON: Right.
MCAFEE: Again, I don't find that that hard
a question to answer. Why is our infrastructure
so lousy? Why are immigration policies, as
far as I can tell, designed by our enemies?
Why are we still turning out the kinds of
workers we neededfifty years ago? If we
could get these things right, that would be
the best thing we could do to improve the
prospects for the American worker, and none
of it is rocket science.
BROOKS: I want to bring up something about
robots and the future. I think—often in
my talks, I put up a picture of a latest model
S class Mercedes and I ask the audience what
it is. Some of them look at it and say it's
a car. Some say it's a Mercedes. And I say,
no, it's an elder-care robot because what
it does is it's got all these safety systems
in which is letting people drive safely longer
than they could have before. And that, I think,
is a—and it gives people dignity to control
their lives longer.
If we look at the population inversion in
Europe, Japan, lagging a bit in China but
coming there, too, and certainly, North America,
I think we're in for a pretty hard time where
the elderly will not have services available
to them. And there's going to be a real pull
on technology to provide those services.
So I would be worried about that because we've
not taken immigrants to—I use my mother
in Australia as an example. Her life—because
she's not very well. She quite old. She's
not able to go to the bathroom by herself,
not able to get into and out of bed by herself.
So her life is—immigrants who've been in
the country for less than three months, want
a job, they come, they're nice people, they
help her with these very personal things but
they didn't come on a refugee boat to help
an old lady go to the bathroom. They—as
soon as they can, they get a better job. So
my mother's life is a succession of people
she's never met coming into her life, interacting
with her in the most intimate ways that she
would never have let my father see her participate
in during her life. I think wanting, you know,
just the technology to be able to get into
and out of bed when you choose, rather than
when the orderly comes, is something that's
going to drive technology and drive robotics.
So I think there'll be more, not robots that
don't have common sense, but more simple robots
in our lives for the nextthirty-five years.
GUPTA: Can I just add—yeah, two more points
andfirst is, like—I'm echoing immigration,
being an immigrant myself and having a hard
time staying here and every given point of
time is a pain. I have taught—I mean, every
Indian who is here getting a PhD thinks about
going back to India because they don't want
to stand outsidean embassy for a hundred—like
hours and hours and having the pain.
So—and further, our immigration policies
are probably not treating technology as good
as money. For example, one example which I
always like is that in the green card, like
the permanent resident process, you have a
categorywhere if you invest $5 million in
U.S. you can get a permanent resident. Why
don't we have a kind of category where if
you want to open a start-up—if you have
ideas to open up start-up, you can raise venture
capitals, you can still stay in this country
is you want to? We are not treating technology
at the same level as—and I have example.
Like, I have a student who wants to open up
a start-up. He has a really good idea but
he cannot open because he's anF1. That kind
of hurts the economy here.
The second point I'm going to sound a little
selfish but I think I still have to say it.
The research funding is, in U.S., it's going
down. In China, it's doubling every—like
in the—from 2008 to 2012, the research funding
in China, which is going to fuel all this
technology drive, is doubled. You can see
the research outputs. They are increasing.
They are doubling. We are going down. Europe
is even better than U.S. That's what is the
most surprising part to me. I would think
given the European economy, they would be
worse. But if you think --- talk to researchers,
like me, Europe has much better way of, like,
in the research funding than America has.
And I think that's kind of—also tells you
that you need to invest more in people like,
not me personally but every—every researcher.
THOMPSON: You made a pretty good case of investing
in you, too. I mean, and I—if anybody's
in this room, this guy's doing some very important
work here.
Rodney, I want to go to something that relates
to this and something that you just said,
and something that, Abhinav, that you've talked
about in a previous panel of yours that I
watched, and that is the example of the robot
taking care of the older person, whether it's
your mother or not, and that is that robots
are very good at certain things. They're very
good at lifting people. They're very good
at carrying things, but they're not good at
emotions. They're not good at morals. So how
does our society change as robots take on
a more profound role? And how does your mother's
relation change if she's being cared for by
a robot who's good at some things but can't
empathize?
BROOKS: Well, I think we are going to see
people and robots together. You know, I much
prefer going to an ATM, which doesn't empathize
at all with me, and in fact, every time I
go to the ATM it ask me whether I want to
speak Spanish. It's been doing that forten
years. Doesn't it know yet I don't want to
speak Spanish? But still, I prefer to go to
the ATM than to a human teller. We don't have
to have the machines have empathy for them
to be useful. We don't have to have the robots
that are helping the elderly have empathy.
I think there's still a place to have people
in the equation, but the nurses and the caregivers
don't have to be doing all the physical labor.
They can be spending much more time just talking
to people.
MCAFEE: If you define empathy a little bit
narrowly as awareness of the emotional state
of another, technologies are actually getting
really good at that. The—there is a system
now that's better than the average guy at
recognizing the emotion on somebody else's
face.
BROOKS: Yeah, but that's a low bar.
MCAFEE: It's a low bar, right? That means
almost nothing, but it's there.
THOMPSON: They probably dress better than
the average guy, too.
MCAFEE: That's right.
THOMPSON: Abhinav, do you agree?
GUPTA: I actually tend to agree a lot more—I
mean, that robots don't need to have emotional—I
mean, there's a lot of research, again, in
this field. There are people doing research
in the field called human-robot interaction,
which is just designed to make humans feel
comfortable with their robots around them.
And I think that's pretty good. We should
do all this research and it's—I don't disagree
with that research. But I agree that for getting
applications out there, for getting products
out there, we probably don't need to have
it immediately. With time, if this happens,
if the robots develop empathy and so on, it
would be pretty—it will be nice but I think
we are—we should, like Rodney's example
of ATM. I think it's a pretty good example
that I also personally sometimes feel—I
would feel freaky if myATM start talking
to me nicely and I was like—maybe it's like
the education of me. Like once I have done
enough number of times a dayat my ATM I
will start to feel comfortable. But if I think
of it this point of time, I will start to—still
feel freaky. I mean, maybe --
MCAFEE: Your freak-out's going to decrease
super fast.
GUPTA: That's what I think.
MCAFEE: I remember how freaked out I was the
first time somebody out there on the Internet
took a—put up a picture and tagged me in
it. It felt like a crazy privacy—and now
it happens all the time.
I hear this argument once in a while that
our humanity is going to be compromised when
the robots gain any kind of emotional capability
or ability to empathize. I fundamentally don't
understand that argument. Our pets have that
ability. They've had it for thousands of years.
We humans are still plenty human. That argument
just makes no sense to me.
THOMPSON: And my children are quite attached
to their Roomba. They were feeding theirRoomba
little bits of bagel the other day because
they thought the Roomba was hungry because
the floor was too clean.
MCAFEE: And if you think about some of our
most vulnerable populations, you brought up
the elderly, think about people—kids with
autism who are doing a great deal of learning
and improvement with these technologies that
don't mind the endless repetition that goes
along with that.
I just read about a really interesting smart
phone app that just by listening to voice
tone, not even the content of a phone call,
can help someone with bipolar disorder understand
when they're in the middle of a swing and
intervene more effectively in that. These
are humanity-increasing technologies, not
decreasing.
THOMPSON: All right. So we're at the Council
on Foreign Relations. Let's talk a little
bit more about the world balance of power.
And you believe that—you were making an
argument on the phone yesterday, or the day
before yesterday, that Mexico was recently
gaining on China, wages were shifting to—jobs
were shifting to Mexico that are now going
to shift back to China because of the trends
we're seeing.
Give us a very brief synopsis of what's about
to happen to the world power dynamics because
of what we've been talking about.
MCAFEE: You mean on the economics front or
the security front?
THOMPSON: Yeah. Let's do military next. We
have about five minutes until we go to Q&A,
so let's talk about global economic power
and then let's talk briefly about the military.
MCAFEE: I think the shortest thing I could
say on that is I would rather have our problems
than just about anybody else's. The wage arbitrage,
as a national growth strategy, I think is
going to become dicier as the technology can
do more and more at lower and lower price
points.
And as we were talking about earlier, I had
the chance to ask David Petraeus and Condoleezza
Rice a little while back, not about the arms
race but about the geek race. And they—while
cybersecurity is scary as hell, they were
really optimistic that the United States was
winning the geek race because we do a good
job of generating them ourselves and because
some of the geekiest—that's a term of praise,
by the way—some of the—a lot of the geekiest
people in the world still want to come here
to build their lives, thank heaven.
THOMPSON: Rodney?
BROOKS: Well, I think we are seeing some shifts
in manufacturing. China, when you go in and
you talk to the big manufacturers there, the
biggest problems in mainland China are recruiting
and retention. There isn't an endless supply
of cheap labor anymore in China. And it's
now true that the labor rates in Mexico are
lower than in China.
That said, I think sort of some catastrophic
event, the smart phone, laptop, that sort
of manufacturing is going to stay in China
for the foreseeable future because they have
built a supply chain which you can't just
migrate.
So what's happening in Mexico is all those
boxes you see in your doctor's office, which
are essentially one circuit board with plastic
wrapped around them, that's cheaper to build
in Mexico. It's doesn't need supply chain.
Sewing goes to Bangladesh because you don't
need a supply chain. But China has this asset,
which is this lock on the supply chain, the
vast volume high-technology electronics manufacturing.
And the Chinese government recognizes that
is—got rid of all import duties on robots
and is even subsidizing Chinese companies
buying robots because there's not enough labor.
THOMPSON: Wow, that's interesting.
Let's talk about the military for a minute.
Rodney, I'm going to take a wild guess that
you've been approached by DARPA roughly 150
times in your career, and yet, you made vacuum
cleaners.
BROOKS: Well, actually, that company did two
things. That was only 50 percent of the business.
The other half of the business was the PackBot
and its brethren. We had 40,000—4,500 of
them in Afghanistan and Iraq.
THOMPSON: What did that robot do?
BROOKS: Doing IED—so at the start of the
conflicts in Afghanistan and Iraq, U.S. doctrine
was you put the youngest—they didn't say
but this is what happened. The youngest guy
in the unit got in the bomb suit, went out
with a stick and poked the roadside bomb.
They're no longer allowed to do that. You
send out the robot. All sorts of good reasons
for doing that. So—I could go into it in
much more detail.
So robots are helping the military. We see
the drones, which aretele-opped, so that's
a little different. But what we saw in Iraq
and Afghanistan was the asymmetry of everything.
What I called at the time, which maybe I have
to change the title, I called at the time
Radio Shack technology. We would see in one
area of Iraq some new technology for a new
sort of roadside bomb. Someone came up with
something and it wasn't expensive technology.
It was stuff you could buy at Radio Shack
and put together. We would then seek—we'd
have to come up with a countermeasure. You
could then see that migrate across the country
in a period of about three or four weeks.
So very simple new ideas are all the—the
asymmetry is always harder to battle against,
or has been up to now.
MCAFEE: In addition to which, the other dynamic
that's going on is that we are democratizing
access to incredibly powerful technologies.
And overall, I'm really optimistic about that
phenomenon but we can rest assured, the bad
guys are going to use the same tool kit to
do us harm in these asymmetric ways. And the
tools they have are going to get better and
better as well.
THOMPSON: Abhinav, what do you see about robots
in our military future?
GUPTA: I mean, a lot of research is being
funded by military. There's no doubt about
that. And I think one area where, again, military
is being really helped by artificial intelligence,
robots, I think these guys have told a lot,
is, again, I think the example of—(inaudible)—the
example is—Palantir Technologies, for example.
They are—they take all—exploit all this
data which they get and they use all this
data to help in cyberterrorism and terrorism
as well. You can track and you can understand
much, much better. You can predict. I think
this predictive analytics is really, really
getting better and better with this AI and
it's going to help us tackle these challenges
with this terrorism and other things. Of course,
we are also going to have problems in foreign
policy because you are able to eavesdrop on
some people and they are not going to feel
happy about it.
BROOKS: Yeah, and just to follow up a little
bit on this asymmetry. What the—those big
companies have is they can employ vast, vast
clouds with GPUs. And the small people may
be really good at doing Twitter, as we see
with ISIL, or ISIS, but they don't have the
access to those vast server clouds that—where
they can do the big data analytics the same
way that the governments can. So there's a
place where maybe the asymmetry hurts the
little guys.
GUPTA: The only problem is that these GPUs
are getting cheaper and cheaper so quickly
that who knows when this GPU will be like
$100 and even --
MCAFEE: GPU for the non-geeks in the audience
is the graphics processing unit that's in
your Xbox.
GUPTA: Thank you for pointing that out. It's
such a common term I don't even realize.
THOMPSON: All right. My predictive analytics
suggest that there will be plenty of questions.
So at this time, I would like to invite members
to join our conversations. Reminder, this
meeting is on the record. Wait for the microphone,
speak directly into it. Please stand, state
your name and affiliation. Please limit yourself
to one question and keep it as concise as
possible so as many members as possible can
speak.
So in the second row, please? Both of you
in the second row, first and then second.
QUESTION: Bettye Musham. Is there any crossover
technology between robots and drones, because
isn't a drone really a flying robot?
BROOKS: Yes. There's a lot of—there's a
lot of common technology there that both—both
of them—I mean, the drones being the small
drones, not the $70 million drones, the small
drones that we're - the FAA is currently arguing
about. Both today's robots and drones have
benefitted greatly from cell phone technology.
It's brought down the cost of sensors, lots
and lots of sensors very cheap, system on
a chip, very powerful computers. They both
use them so there's a lot of commonality there.
GUPTA: I think what I'm quite certain—I
mean, you can think of it as the planning
for rewards. I mean, the normal robot, like
Baxter, or a drone will be very similar because
they have to see the same world, they have
to react to the same world and that's why
I would say there is a very high overlap.
It's just that the capabilities of these two
robots are different and that's it.
THOMPSON: OK. Again, in the second row?
QUESTION: Robert Kaiser. I'm curious, Mr.
Gupta, if you could give us some examples
of what NEIL can do. I'm having a hard time
imagining what the payoff from NEIL is in
a practical way.
GUPTA: OK. So I think this is something which
I have to—I was hoping someone would ask
it. And there was a discussion on the phone
as well that—why understanding? Why do all
this common sense and something like that.
Think—let's think of autonomous cars. All
of think autonomous cars are going to come
very soon. I'm sure we are reading it everywhere
that autonomous cars are coming tomorrow,
or something like that. Let's think your best
pattern-matching technologies trying to solve
autonomous cars. So you have to understand
that our world has two kinds of distributions;
things which will happen a lot. Fifty percent
of these things will happen a lot. For example,
cars driving on roads, cars taking turns.
You will see them every day. There's lot of
data that—(inaudible)—of these common
things that happen in our life. And autonomous
cars, they'll be really good at understanding
these common things that happen every day
in the life.
Now think of rare things that happen. Now
you will be surprised that 50 percent of the
things that are in our world are very, very
rare. By rare, I mean they might happen once
in a month or even much, much less. How would
you adapt to those? There's not enough data.
Your—all your pattern technology—matching
technologies will start to fail. So what will
you do in that case? In that case, you will
need common sense.
And a very simple example of this I can tell
you is let's, again, go back to autonomous
cars and think of this as—let us suppose
your car is driving on a road, it's an autonomous
car. There is a wire which is crossing the
street and this wire breaks on one end. The
wire goes like this. You all know what's going
to happen because it's still attached to one
point. It's going to show a pendulum motion
and it's going to come back like this. What
an autonomous car sees, it goes like this.
There's nothing in front of me now, I can
go. And it's a live wire so you don't want
to touch it or cross it.
But it has no idea how the world works. It
has never seen wires crossing like this because
how many times have you seen wires like this?
So we humans can reason out and say, OK, I
should stop, I should not drive through this,
whereas an autonomous car will continue driving
through it and it might get electrified or
something.
I am just, again, a very rare, rarest of examples
and you can think of many more examples where
you would need common sense like this.
BROOKS: Can I just reiterate that? John Leonard
at MIT, one of the founders of a technology,
SLAM, which is critical for autonomous cars,
put a dash cam on his car and had his students
count the events which were unusual and which
were not going to be in the big databases
and, indeed, came up with numbers very similar
to what you say.
THOMPSON: So you're hope is that through your
software you'll be able to ultimately teach
an autonomous car not to do those things?
GUPTA: I mean, it might be able to reason
out these things. It might be able to learn
about pendulum motions and it can say, OK,
if I see things like this, it has to come
back while it's still attached to that thing
on the top.
THOMPSON: OK.
In the fourth row? Yes, right there on the
left.
QUESTION: Stephen Blank, University of Ottawa.
This is about jobs and strategy. A little
context quickly. I graduated from high school,
a rural slum high school in 1957. We didn't
have very much academics. People didn't go
to college, but most of my classmates had
good jobs in the sense that they lived—they
consumed as middle class consumers throughout
most of their life.
OK. Question today. How do we provide access
to the jobs, however many are being created?
Do you educate people up for those jobs or
do you make those jobs more accessible to
people who do not have the educational apparatus—don't
have an increased education apparatus? Which
do you do, up or down? How do you do it?
MCAFEE: I don't think that's an either/or
question. I think both are clearly going on.
And like Rod points out, the bargain seems
to be shifting kind of quickly these days
away from guarantees of something that felt
more like a guarantee of a job and benefits
to a series of more spot engagements, and
Uber is a really great example of that.
Opinions on that shift are really sharply
divided. I personally am a huge fan of companies,
like Uber, not because I like getting from
point A to point B, but Uber is putting labor
back into the economy at a time when we really
need labor. If we're not happy about some
characteristics of that job or what people—the
life of an Uber driver, great. Let's intervene
with policy. If we don't like where that person
is, let's top them up with something like
an earned income tax credit. Let's make educational
options more available so they can upskill
themselves if that's a good path forward.
But for heaven sake, if we've got companies
that are adding labor to the economy, why
are we demonizing them? It doesn't make sense
to me.
BROOKS: But to—sort of your question up
or down, without robots that we're putting
in factories, we're making it so the ordinary
factory worker can learn—teach themselves
how to program it. You know, if I had my smart
phone in my hand, imagine you had to go take
a community college course in order to learn
how to use a smart phone. They wouldn't have
taken off as they have. What we put in—what
the companies that build them put in there
was technology that teaches the consumer how
to use them as they first use them and so
it brings the consumer into that world.
I think from looking at industrial equipment,
the way to go is to have the industrial equipment
be smarter and bring the person into the world
and be able to understand it so you don't
need to go off and be trained in a particular
technology that's going to change inten
years anyway, so it's got to be continuous
on-the-job learning, and technology has to
provide that.
MCAFEE: It also appears that about, again,
since the turn of the century, you still want
to go to college because the wage premium
on a college education is a pretty good one.
But even college-educated people are not seeing
their real wages go up. So this idea that
getting more skills will always put you on
an upward trajectory of earnings, that really
appears not to be true, at least since the
turn of the century. The only folk who it
looks like are seeing their real earnings
go up are the 1 percent, the 1 percent of
the 1 percent.
QUESTION: We have a—(inaudible)—core of
people in this country who are not going to
go to college, and that's the reality. Those
are the people who need some sort of access
to jobs.
MCAFEE: Which is why I'm a huge fan of Uber.
BROOKS: Yeah, those Uber drivers don't have
to go to college and they're still being able
to be—do something pretty good.
THOMPSON: OK. Do we have a next question here
on the right? Whichever one of you --
QUESTION: Steve Rodriguez. I'm a venture partner
with a VC company here in New York. So an
area I focus on is technology with military
applications. What in your, I guess, estimation,
is the biggest barriers to companies like
iRobot or even like Helen Greiner's company,
CyPhy, is a former colleague of yours? What's
their biggest barrier to entering or dealing
with the military, from your perspective?
Yeah, I'll stick with one question.
BROOKS: Having living that with iRobot, we
would not have gotten anywhere near as far
if there hadn't been some wars going on that
we had an answer for. Very hard to break into
the acquisition cycle for a smaller company.
The bigger companies really do have it locked
down pretty well and it's very hard to get
in. It was just that we had a technology that
no one else had but it never got into a program
of record. As soon as the wars ran down, iRobot's
share of—the percentage of their military
business decreased rapidly within the company.
So it's the—the companies that are there
are still taking enormous parts of the military
budget on things, you know, as throw weight,
if you like, whereas maybe the threats of
the future are going to be very different
sorts of threats, and that worries me.
THOMPSON: The gentleman who is also in the
fourth row?
QUESTION: Les Baquiran, Alpine Capital Advisors.
My question is that I think we could all agree
that technology has lowered the price for
consumers in a lot of different things, but
there's two core industries that it really
hasn't impacted, at least to my expectations,
and that's really health care and education,
because health care and education have far
outpaced normal inflation. So what do you
see in the future in those particular sectors,
technology, AI, robotics, helping to lower
the cost of both?
MCAFEE: Larry Summers makes this point in
a really vivid way. He says if you go look
at the bundle of stuff that makes up the CPI,
the Consumer Price Index, where we get our
inflation figures from, it was set to 100
in—I'm going to get the year wrong—likethirty
years ago,forty years ago.
(UNKNOWN): (OFF MIKE)
MCAFEE: '83?
(UNKNOWN): '82.
MCAFEE: '82? So that—everything was 100
in '82. A color TV today is 10. A hospital
visit and a college education are at 600.
So I couldn't agree more. We are not seeing
the kind of crazy price declines in these
huge industries that we're seeing elsewhere.
What's going to bring them there? Opening
up these markets, getting rid of the incumbent's
advantage. Education, my home industry, is
a cartel. And the only thing that I think
is going to change the real price of education
is when employers start valuing signals that
don't come with an expensive—other than
an expensive degree from an accredited university.
I can't wait for that day to come.
BROOKS: Let me talk about health care very
briefly. I think where it impacts health care
is when you change the rules and change the
way it works. So putting sensors that detect
when a person is going to need help is going
to—so that you intercede earlier in the
situation, don't have them going into hospitals,
staying there. That's going to start changing
things because the hospital visits continue
to increase.
We're seeing companies start to do that. It's
getting bundled with things like Nest, with
home security systems. And it's going to be
that children of the—their parents investing
in that technology to keep their parents healthier
longer at home.
And then there's—most of—a big part of
health care costs go to the last few months
of life and that's a big moral issue. How
do we rethink what we want for ourselves,
you know, in the last few months of life?
And the problem is you never know when the
last few months are so it's a terrible bargain
you have to make.
GUPTA: I think the internet of things is basically
what you are pointing out is that the sensors,
the smart homes and everything, I think they're
really going to change health care, and especially
once we have enough analytics on them. We
are still in the process of developing data.
I think it's the—I mean, for me, when I
think, it's all about data. And now, at this
point of time, we don't have enough data in
the health are, but because we are now starting
to purchase a sensor that's become so, so
cheap, it's now at a point where it's starting
to go and basically create applications out
of this.
BROOKS: Even simple things right now. Some
companies are putting sensors in—they notice
when a person isn't getting out of bed and
they—the health supplier then sends someone
to check on them before they sit there for
three days and get into a chronic situation.
THOMPSON: My sensor just went off and said
there are more questions. Over here, please?
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE), from McKenzie. Mentioning
the internet of things, the actual internet,
we've been reminded vividly, is very hackable,
very insecure and we're anxious about it.
So as we move the internet of things and more
robots, are you worrying more about making
sure your stuff is hack-free? How are you
thinking about that, Rodney?
BROOKS: That's a real problem.
THOMPSON: Have you ever had Baxter get hacked?
BROOKS: Well, interestingly, you know, Baxter,
we started selling him to small companies
that didn't have networks, so Baxter is currently
not networked. So we have not had Baxter hacked.
GUPTA: I think it is a real fear. I mean,
there is the more and more power goes into
the hand of computers. This isgoing to—but
I think, again, the hope is that we are—I
mean, there is lots of research a lot of work
on this field and hopefully we are not going
to—I mean, hopefully we are not—will be
in a bad position. So that has to be a downside.
THOMPSON: Wow. Pure pessimism across the panel.
OK. Back on the left, please?
QUESTION: Darryll Hendricks. The panel, earlier,
made it clear you didn't think there was an
imminent existential threat from, you know,
robots. And I'd be interested in the panel's
views on consciousness. Is that something
that you see as, you know, coming in decades,
coming, you know, hundreds of years, or never?
THOMPSON: That is a hard question.
BROOKS: Well, let me say I've written about
this some. In principle, we can have conscious
machines because I believe we are machines.
You know, when you take biology 101 it doesn't
say "and then the two molecules, you know,
and the receptors come near to each other
and the soul intervenes and they lock together".
We have a mechanistic description of ourselves
and that's what modern science is based on.
Whether we're smart enough to build such a
machine is one question, and whether we understand
it enough at the moment for it to be a problem
that we can work on today, I think is a totally
different question. Some questions people
had back in the days of Leonardo da Vinci
but it took hundreds of years to get there.
The conscious—in my group, my lab, I used
to—we used to call it "the C word". We were
not allowed to say it because—and we had
this deal where we'd go to the international
consciousness conferences once everyten
years to see if there'd been any progress.
And so far, I haven't detected any.
THOMPSON: Can you—let's pause for a second.
I didn't ask you to define deep learning earlier
in the panel, but I was tempted. I'm going
to ask you to try to define consciousness
as it applies to a robot.
BROOKS: Oh, I can't define it as it applies
to a person. I mean, we only have this --
MCAFEE: I've heard it called a suitcase word,
in that you put in it whatever you want and
you kind of carry it around. Philosophers
have been debating what this thing is for
hundreds of years. It's an incredibly hard
problem. I couldn't agree—I rarely find
myself saying this, I could not agree with
Rod more on this. Conceptually, we're machines.
Conceptually, there's no reason that we can't—we
don't have the faintest idea of how the brain
actually works. We understand some things
pretty well. This is a huge mystery.
THOMPSON: All right. And anew rule; when
you ask a question, please identify whether
you're a human or a machine.
In the front row, please?
QUESTION: Hi, Laeticia Garriott de Cayeux
and I'm a humanoid. So you all took, across
the panel, the position that we're not going
to be the generation that pull the plugs for
this AI that surpasses us, and that's your
opinion. Can we hear arguments other than—and
we hear you, it's extremely hard. Computational
power is not today the capability where it
should be. But what are your arguments that
we should trust and go with your opinion and
not the opinion of Elon Musk, Stephen Hawking
and others?
BROOKS: So if we look at actually one of the
places which makes this prediction, did a
careful study of the lastsixty years of
such predictions, the mode of where they—the
predictions were—were alwaysfifteen totwenty
years in the future. So we know the vast majority
of those predictions were totally wrong because
everyone always predictsfifteen totwenty
years in the future. So historically, people
have been wrong in predicting. Why would they
be right now? We have no reason to believe—to
know that they're right now. And certainly,
Elon Musk has no reason to believe it. He's
just making that up.
I liken it to—this whole thing about the
singularity, I liken itto witches. We used
to burn witches. Why did we burn witches,
because we believed by existed and then we
found them. So if you believe there's going
to be a singularity where there's, you know,
the great technology changes us and lets us
live forever and have everything we want,
then you're going to expect it's going to
happen on a date.
QUESTION: Yeah, I'm asking from our perspective,
not their perspective. I'm just asking yours.
BROOKS: Because I've been working in this
forforty years and we've made that much
progress on that much.
MCAFEE: I went to a conference in January
of this year exactly devoted to this question,
where there were people who spent their careers
in the discipline who believe very differently
than you do, who were giving these predictions
about 2035, 2040. What was interesting is,
again, they weretwenty years from right
now, which is the common thing that the singulatarians
always say. Their point was that we have made
progress on one or two of those really, really
fundamental challenges and we feel like we
are on a trajectory that looks like this for
making progress on the rest of them because
we've got so much computational power. We've
got better insights into the brain. We can
map things down to the individual neuron on
the brain that's going to let us understand
how it works. I hear their arguments. I'm
still with you on this.
BROOKS: Elon Musk was at that.
MCAFEE: Yes, he was.
THOMPSON: Abhinav, where are you on singularity
and --
GUPTA: Yeah. So I actually think it's very—(inaudible)—and
there's a very good reason to believe so.
First of all, what does singularity mean?
I mean, what are we talking about here? We
are talking about computers deciding themselves
what is good, what is bad. Right now, we are
making all these applications with a task
in mind. And we are thinking of making a computer
with no task deciding what is good for themselves,
what is bad for themselves and just hypothesizing
these kinds of questions which we need to
solve. And I'm 100 percent sure there's actually
no serious researcher who's thinking of these
questions at this point of time.
BROOKS: But I—I want to say one more thing.
MCAFEE: Rod feels strongly about this.
BROOKS: That the basis of this belief is that
AI is going to get so good that it's going
to self-improve, it's going to rewrite itself.
We do not have a single system that can write
a ten-line program, like any person who takes
a first semester of programming. It cannot
restructure it, even in a ten-line program.
If we were going to have something that could
take these enormously complex systems with
billions of lines, surely we should've gone
somewhere between zero andten lines of code.
We're not there.
So what this whole argument has made me do
is decide, that's my project. I want to build
that system.
MCAFEE: At the same time—I'll take the other
side of this argument. At the same time, there
was just a paper published in Nature. A pretty
serious team of geeks out of London built
a machine to learn to play '80s vintage Atari
videogames without being taught the rules
or any of the right strategies for playing
them. That computer is now the world's best
Space Invaders player. It's now the world's
best Breakout player. You will never score
a point from it in Pong. It's a really impressive
achievement. I'm still with you.
GUPTA: Again, the task is defined here. It
has to do good on that task. This whole question
of meta-thinking—and this is what Rodney
is saying—what—I mean, we need to solve
meta-thinking and I don't think - I'm pretty
serious about it. There's no one actually
who's taking on meta-thinking right now. We
are still at a much lower level. We still
want to solve simple tasks.
BROOKS: And last thing. Before we get robot—before
we get AI that's going to take over the world,
we're going to getreally annoying AIs. And
we'll be annoyed at them and stop them. It's
not a Hollywood movie where suddenly it comes.
THOMPSON: So the award for the question that
most flummoxed the panel goes to the woman
in the front row.
Now in the fourth row, please?
BROOKS: She's a robot.
QUESTION: Rick Thoman, Corporative Perspectives,
Columbia University and also former executive
at Xerox and IBM. I wanted to talk a little
bit about the futurologist aspect of all of
this. You know, a major consulting firm was
asked by a big telecomtwenty-five years
ago to do a study of how big the world's cell
phone business could get. And they concluded
it could get to be 150,000 units. Now of course,
they couldn't image that the cell phones didn't
weightwelve pounds and didn't cost $7,000.
So talk to me about a world of robots in which
they costs $100 or $10. And are there such
a thing—is it imaginable that there could
be personal robots that are two inches by
two inches or one foot by one foot? So --
MCAFEE: It's not imaginable; it's guaranteed.
I completely agree; futurology is a cheap
ploy and very few futurologists ever get called
on how bad their predictions actually are.
QUESTION: Right. Exactly.
MCAFEE: So it's a sucker's game. The things
that I can say with great confidence, Moore’s
Law, this exponential improvement in the elementsof
computing is not about to run out of gas.
We've got a generation more of it to go. The
amount of data available in the world is going
to continue to explode, especially as the
internet of things and all these sensors happen.
And geeks out there are going to take that
computational power and that ocean of data
and do things that are going to astonish us.
Those three things I know.
BROOKS: I agree.
THOMPSON: In the middle, on the—in the right?
Yes, please.
QUESTION: Hi, David Preiser, I believe I'm
a human although Gödel would tell us it's
not possible to actually know. So I read your
book. I thought it was great. The --
MCAFEE: Thank you. I think we're done.
QUESTION: No, no. So—but if I read some
of the import of it, it seems like we're—we're
bisecting ourselves between those geeks who
will create amazing things and those who are
not able to enter that promised land, don't
have the drive, the intellectual capacity,
the interest, whatever limitation there is.
And yet, all those people will need something
to do.
And I wonder, and I heard something that was
interesting, which is, well, isn't part of
the potential of the machines to dumb down
a whole bunch of tasks so that people can
feel like they're participating in this world
and doing something useful, when in fact,
the machine is doing most of the work?
I once read a story like that where a doctor
had this fantastic mechanized doctor's bag
that was programmed with all medical knowledge
and he really believed he was a doctor, when,
in fact, the doctor bag was the doctor. So
what do you think about that?
BROOKS: I want to answer both questions at
once. One of the possibilities that will happen
is that we will see the maker movement in
the same way we saw the Homebrew Computer
Club takeover computation from the big companies,
the NCRs, the Honeywells, all those companies
which were great computer companies, Deck,
et cetera. And that Homebrew Computer Club
turned in to be the fountain of productivity.
The maker movement might turn into the fountain
of productivity and there'll be much more—many
more people doing making than there have been
in the past and a whole locus of where / what
makes a company may change, in the same way
computer companies completely got obliterated
in the '80s by a whole new generation.
And I'm not saying, you know, using a cell
phone analogy, making it easy to use doesn't
mean it's dumbing it down so that people aren't
actually doing stuff with it. It just makes
it more convenient to do things and you can
get up to the threshold of using them. I think
that's different from fooling them. I'm not
arguing—I don't think it's they're fooling
them. I think we can still provide useful
interfaces for people so they can become much
more powerful and much more powerful in their
making. The same way if you're at Xerox, you
know, the laser writer, the laser printer
let people do typesetting where they didn't—they
couldn't do it before.
MCAFEE: What's interesting is that as the
technologies have proliferated and really
democratized access to innovation and to making
things—we've been doing this for thirty-plus
years—the economy has moved in the other
direction. The economy has moved toward more
concentration, the big guys getting bigger,
the workforce becoming more polarized instead
of less.
So when I hear about this promised future
land of the maker movement that's going to
restore middle class opportunity, it's arguing
exactly against the trends that are pretty
clear in the evidence so far. So I'm really
worried about this polarization of opportunity
and of mobility. I think it's already a challenge.
I think it's going to get a lot bigger. And
what we do about that is going to be the challenge,
I believe, that defines us for the next generation
or so.
The good news is the problem we're going to
face is not the problem of scarcity, is not
the problem of not enough to go around. And
I find it really important not to lose sight
of that fundamentally fantastic news. Keynes
was right; we're going to get away with what
he called the economic problem of allocating
in the face of scarcity. Fantastic. The distribution
problem is a tough problem, but like you know,
we put a quote from Voltaire to start off
one of our chapters. He said that work saves
us from three great evils; boredom, vice and
need. Of those three, I find the need easiest
to take care of.
THOMPSON: Back there on the right?
QUESTION: Thanks. Jamie Metzl, I'm an investor
and novelist. I would love if you could say
a few words about the future of robotic pets.
BROOKS: Well, I do apologize for having let
loose the genre of pets riding on Roombas
by having the Roomba, and therefore—people
do treat their Roombas with a reverence that
I could not have believed. Hardcore—hardcore
Marines in war zones treating their PackBot
with a reverence that I could not believe.
So it is not too hard to trigger some of our
empathy for machines. And there will be startups
which try to do that because they're going
to make a buck and so there will be machines
around that some people treat as pets. Other
people have disdain for. We saw that just
last week when Boston Dynamics, now owned
by Google, showed their new four-legged robot
walking and the people were kicking it and
they got eviscerated in the press for --
MCAFEE: For kicking the poor robot.
THOMPSON: All right. We have two minutes left.
Last question here on the right, please?
QUESTION: Eyrique Miller from JPMorgan. I
guess this ties into the last two questions.
So I have two daughters that areten and
five. They have a Zoomer, both of them, which
is the dog that you can teach and do tricks.
And I guess my question is, and this is sort
of skipping the current generation of college
students, but are we doing enough for the
youth that are, you know, at the younger age
to educate them in terms of robotics and actually
to be participants in where you think this
is going?
MCAFEE: No, absolutely not. We're teaching
--
QUESTION: But what can we be doing then if
we're not doing enough?
GUPTA: We are not doing enough but there is,
I think, again—I agree that we are not doing
enough, first of all, I should say that.
But I—for example, in Carnegie Mellon, I
see every day these capable students coming,
like, four-year kids coming and making robots
in the labs. I think that is the best hope
we have.
We need to, first of all—I mean, if you
don't have to wait until college education
for robots to be inside their—inside your
education. I think we need to take it much
faster. It could be—start with a very small
system—small, like easy things they make
on. But I think there is—I mean, there should
be something which could be done for that
this education goes to—starts as early as
possible, rather than waiting until the last
moment, like the last four years, the bachelor
technology or bachelors, to do this thing.
BROOKS: There is a little—and this is a—this
is—you spoke as a parent. I'm going to speak
as a parent. One of my daughters has started
a company to build STEM toys for girls age
seven to nine and it was actually at New York
Toy Fair two weeks ago. There were a whole
bunch of actually women-run companies building
engineering toys for girls. So we're starting
to see that. That may help the next generation
be exposed as they're getting out. And they're
getting pretty wide distribution. So there
are entrepreneurs wanting to do this. Her
major investor is Mark Cuban, but that's because
he has daughters, too. So the UVCs—if you'll
just invest in girls' toys companies that
will be a lot better.
THOMPSON: Elon Musk will not be investing
after this panel.
Thank you very much. We all have to get back
to our jobs before they're taken by robots.
Thank you to Malcolm and Carolyn Wiener and
thank you to our panel.
END